oh i'm back and i'm also leaving next
week remember i said that okay cool
i'm leaving when the new minecraft
update comes out that i've been waiting
for
for months
[Music]
anyway memes to distract from the pain
periods every time he takes a break
i go to japan oh
japan time is so very good now i went to
sweden
to see my parents and my sister it was
great
marcia i pooped me what the hell is this
meme template
get this out of here no i will not be
known as
shower guy that ain't me i'm the guy
that
looks at me you know i'll take shower
shake
pewdiepie when he's looking at a ufo
footage pewdiepie when he's trying to
figure out how much a ten dollar
uber ride costs i still don't know
it doesn't say on their website the
prize always fluctuates
depending on different rates in that
area that's a bit random video
i don't know it just bothers me how many
conspiracy theories are out there and
people still believing them
i don't mean to be a party pooper right
but i'm glad you guys enjoyed it because
it's something
different and i want to keep doing more
different adam warlock
707 who's been on the white 20 times
you want to see qpr i've never heard of
that
bless his soul i already forgotten it
that's about that
foods has been on every y that has ever
existed
that's right i don't get enough
recognition
pewdiepie oh that's a guy that is always
on the y he makes the best memes
the mafia in my hometown ran a pizza
chain i've seen this
as a friend and it got so popular that
the head of the family just stopped
doing crimes
and they do pizza full time now that's
how mafia works that's a wholesale
why we here it is oh you ruined it
congratulations it's supposed to be me
and my sister
and i this is very uncomfortable to look
at i'm moving on
felix i'm going to use you very kidding
me
yes the recording wow
so i can't make the joke about the
microphone anymore
because then the video gets demonetized
now youtube has decided that's too far
but you know you know me i'm all about
pushing it to the limit
can i give it a little huh what are you
gonna do youtube demonetize this
you can't demonetize love it you get the
money guys love i just love it
i'll give him a little big head kiss
close your eyes
[Music]
low quality minecraft me hey hey we got
the ikea tower right there baby
dude that was such a wholesome moment
okay there's my favorite fish to fish in
sweden which is macro
they taste so good it's called dirty
ning i don't know
what it's called in english when you
drag the bait from the boat
and you move the boat but we caught a
ton of macro and it was so exciting
but as soon as we got him up i was like
[Music]
dad help me and my mom storm scene i
don't know where it goes
right with a knife right how are you
cute it's like watching a
dexter's episode it was amazing
my mom's a badass you know the episode
is gonna be fire when these two show up
there it is
okay my sister loves the memes so please
make more
my dad loves the jurgen klopp i assume
there will be a meme like that as well
oh my god this could be us
austin bradley you and me wow that's
also weird
well done photoshopping i mean that's
not bad i'll give you that
that sort of go it can't be that easy
haha it took a [ __ ] in the shower it is
that easy
wow they are so foolish
just learn from my mistakes okay if you
have a funny story that you think is
funny
never share never share funny story go
haha it never is
so sad that joe died from ligma what
thang man
your mama what is this meme template
get out leave us 200 plus games in my
library
that one game good move
after it here it is after year and a
half we could finally meet up so nice
i had such a good time uh you all talk
about no ears and no legs but what's the
last time
you mean when's the last time you saw
felix
answer answer it in the comment top
comment
when's it your supply of spin shower
okay
no no you did not do that you did not
you did not do
that oh thank god
this channel has done nothing but
regress i mean evolve
but backwards for a long time felix and
his sis
look like they're about to take on the
neighbor's kid
hell yeah hey yo is that felix
cajellberg in the back what the
uh we played paddle my parents have been
talking about it so much you have to
play you have to blame lion
super fun love it you're such a dumb
animal yeah yeah okay one in 30 people
admit they have pooped in the shower
one in 30 people 29 people are
liars liars confess
1 in 30 and i have 110 million subs
that means quick math feelings six
thousand have pooped in the shower
confess your sins this is no judge zone
whoa let's go 53
servants they wash themselves fewer than
seven times a week
no well i guess maybe weakness is okay
sixty-eight percent of men and fifty-six
percent of women say they irregular pee
and shower
hell l
watch their peepee in the sink likes
go based spray speed
with deodorant let's go have you ever
done a porno shower should have been the
train
let's go let's go i'm not alone
pooping shower people are out there when
they will rise up
top 88 that means 22 players didn't make
it past the first bridge
all right now that i hear it i okay i
got out
it's 30 i'm sorry uh do you own a 3d
printer
yes you're hired
[Music]
well people make cool [ __ ] it's not that
easy
you do it then that one duo who
challenge you to a pokemon battle
it's the same joke but my sister will
happy
i'm going to use you for sharing right
which i appreciate
you know what i might do it again maybe
i do
uh everything maybe i live in shower you
can't stop me i'm an adult i do what i
wish
month of june begins companies on their
way to change their logo be like
rainbow right and so
that's the pewdiepie channel sorry
change the border to rainbow
that's right on this channel we care
about
i'm too scared of saying anything
because i'm terrified uh we care about
love and kindness
we stand by it hundred percent
there it is
it's naruto he loves naruto me taking a
picture in my garden
the guy trying to be in the phone
there's always that one [ __ ] dude
don't look away from the camera not into
it oh wait that is me ah
i will not be not off
no i embrace it i am shower guy
i'm not afraid to admit it and i'll do
it again i'm gonna shower later actually
am i
who knows what's gonna happen that's
what's fun about life you never know
when you will
shower you never know it could happen to
you it could happen to me
oh yeah we played a poly poly bridge for
a stream go
and i spent an hour on a bridge i didn't
realize i spent like an hour
don't laugh like i laugh at the same
time that's weird stuff it felix could
jail for
you copycat sellers posting with our
younger selves
they would if you think we look alike we
actually don't look that much like on
this photo but
well if i wear glasses we're
indistinguishable dude my dad is 64. can
you believe it
then who the hell is felix shelburne
pewds explain
i can explain pewdiepie tuber simulator
best game clearly hell yeah
let's go the tights are turning shower
game shower ship squad squad up
oh that's great i like that
loneliest countries in the world sweden
united kingdom
japan
oh [ __ ] well not me not if you're
in shower game never lonely this house
will change the world
crazy bill you're there felix
[Laughter]
good meme oh book review yes
yes i know i'm thinking about doing
something a little different
okay we do something different next time
like uh you know
when you're like oh you're right and you
got like oh my gosh my face you have to
close your eyes and you're having those
intrusive thoughts of like the ghost
coming in
okay this is
[Laughter]
if you're gonna kill me you're gonna be
real freaked out about this
and people are weird about me sitting in
the shower
big up pencil arsenal well done that's
so funny
fear's trying to solve seven plus five
puts in the ufo video no it's 15.
come on there it is narrative no
leggings wow what a great photoshop i
can
barely tell that it is well done what's
three plus seven thirteen
a little physics professor felix right
now i may be navy but i'm not stupid
i said twelve as a joke but it's the
correct answer
it's nine
foods in 2020 blurry 1080p pizza in 2021
crystal clear baby crystal
clear and looking hella handsome dude
nice beer bro
sweet on top of the list when it comes
to the loneliest country how did this
happen
bro get out of here why what did we do
united kingdom yeah i yeah
brazil kenya not kenya
[ __ ] studies hell yeah
well happy birthday to your average dad
one one
one three one four daughter happy
birthday
i did i can't believe i spent an hour i
didn't even realize i spent so long
doing something productive for my future
watching swedish man struggle one hour
to build a bridge
but the payoff when i got that bridge it
was incredible
oh they're drinking g field waste
[Music]
10 out of 10. beautiful that's how we do
it now
oh cute
that's awesome what the [ __ ] happened to
comments on reddit
what um kind of cringe they're singing
found the perfect shower for felix oh my
god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my it's so beautiful i love it
oh hell yeah looking good i had those
shoes
oh i didn't splash we're so stupid
how could we mess this one up oh a bunch
of dummy dumbs now
the man that shower just school this oh
my god
there it is happy pride
i'm going to use you for recording rain
the memes lately are so obscure what the
[ __ ]
it's this or in the shower but i love it
10 out of 10.
well done guys okay i leave there might
be more videos but i go
but i see you soon with minecraft update
don't watch anyone else do the minecraft
update
because i have
okay watch whatever all right bro first
yeah feeling lonely with all the crew
and you can't go to the zoo
even ones that i can't see just download
it for free
for free
i got something for you
[Applause]
you